1485 in Henry Tudor has defeated Richard
the third at the Battle of Bosworth
Field he was subsequently crowned King
Henry the seventh Henry married
Elizabeth the daughter of the Yorkist
King Edward the fourth which United the
claims of both the houses of York and
Lancaster into the House of Tudor this
brought about the end of the Wars of the
Roses and many historians also consider
this to be the end of the medieval
period in England in the beginning of
the early modern age
Henry's early reign was plagued by the
issue of stability and he faced many
rebellions notably that of Lambert
Simnel in 1487 who was backed by
powerful Lords such as John della pol
the Earl of Lincoln
Henry crushed the rebels at the Battle
of Stoke and even pardoned similar who
was simply a puppet in 1489 Henry in an
attempt to strengthen his position at
home signed the Treaty of Medina del
Campo with the kingdom of Aragon this
treaty arranged a marriage between
Henry's eldest son and heir Prince
Arthur and Catherine the daughter of the
Aragon ease King tensions and unrest
continued for the next few years until
another Pretender to the throne a man
called Perkin Warbeck made himself known
in 1491 war Bek claimed to be richard of
shrewsbury the second son of Edward the
fourth and the younger brother of Edward
the fifth Warbeck spent five years
gathering supporters which included the
King of Scotland with whom war Bek
launched a raid into the north in 1497
Henry levy taxes to raise his own army
which caused rioting in Cornwall the
reason for this was that the Cornish who
had a very strong regional identity in
the majority of whom did not even speak
English did not believe they should pay
for an army to fight in the north the
riots turned to rebellion and an army
marched on London but was ultimately
defeated Henry then turned his attention
to Scotland and after some fighting
managed to agree to what was called the
Treaty of Perpetual peace called so
because everyone should have dreams
immediately after this war Bek landed in
Cornwall and raised enough a rebellious
army which laid siege to exeter this
each failed Warwick was captured and
soon after paraded through London and
hanged
Henry's efforts to cement the House of
Tudor were widespread and included a
large-scale purge of any Yorkists or
potential threats which lasted for
decades harsh restrictions were placed
on inheritance rights and financial
penalties were common in 1499 Prince
Arthur now being of age was married to
Catherine of Aragon but the two wouldn't
meet until late 15:01 when she arrived
in England the marriage wasn't a
particularly long one since Arthur died
in 1502 forever robbing England of
having an actual King Arthur attempts
began immediately to have Catherine
married the now heir to England Prince
Henry but things were complicated some
of these complications were due to a
succession crisis in
Casteel which was basically unified with
Aragon and because it was against church
law for someone to marry their brother's
widow a law which will become very
relevant shortly
King Henry would go on to die in 1509 in
his reign was ultimately a successful
one since he secured his new dynasty
henry was also responsible for securing
important alliances and centralizing
power which made some of his ministers
very unpopular because nobody likes
being taxed or being told what to do
henry also importantly stabilized the
country and fixed its finances which is
why his death was not followed by a war
of succession he was succeeded by his
son Henry who had recently married
Catherine of Aragon and was crowned King
Henry the eighth's
Henry wanted to be liked and so at his
father's most unpopular ministers
arrested tried for high treason and
executed so Henry saw himself as a
successor to the likes our bed with the
third in Henry the fifth meaning he
wanted to be a king remembered for his
glorious conquests since Henry didn't
care much for governing he left most of
it to a man called Thomas Wolsey Henry
liked Wolsey because he did as he was
told and seldom said no to the King
which the King was a fan of what was he
soon after was made the Bishop of
Lincoln the Archbishop of York a
Cardinal of Roman in 1515 he was
appointed as the Lord Chancellor the
highest office in the land two years
prior to this henry had done what all
good English kings did invade France
this was a part of a larger war called
the War of the League of Cambrai in the
England's most notable allah was the
holy roman empire Henry led his army
personally and won a victory at the
Battle of the Spurs there was an attempt
at peace in 1515 but this all fell
through when the new French king came to
the throne Frances the first what was he
did manage to secure a peace with France
three years later which laid the
foundation for the Treaty of London
which made peace between the European
powers this piece was literally supposed
to last forever but fun fact No
two years later Henry and Francis met to
celebrate their newfound peace here what
was later called the field of the cloth
of gold because of the tents being gold
this was essentially a very expensive
attempt at one-upmanship by both Kings
but it would have meant more had the
peace actually lasted in the next war
English forces got within 50 miles of
Paris however they didn't receive the
reinforcements they were promised by the
Holy Roman Empire and so retreated and
abandoned the war after this Francis the
first was captured by the Holy Roman
Emperor the French lost the war in
England got nothing which upset Henry
after Francis was released in 1526 he
asked Henry for an alliance against the
Holy Roman Emperor Charles v which Henry
agreed to and so another war at home was
he was reforming the methods of tax
collection as well as regulating farming
practices Wolsey was also made
people legged that is a personal
representative with the Pope and he was
so powerful that he was often referred
to as alter Rex or the other king being
a papal legate gave what was the immense
authority over the church which he
attempted to reform but not much came of
it
the writings of Martin Luther which were
disseminated thanks to the invention of
the printing press had a great impact on
the coastal reform the Dutch scholar
Erasmus was calling for a pure form of
spirituality in stayed in Cambridge from
1511 to 1514 Erasmus his friend Thomas
Moore was also a renowned thinker whose
most notable work utopia questioned the
ethical foundations of society henry's
position on church reform was made clear
in 15-20 where Martin Luther criticized
the seven sacraments Henry jumped to
their defense and wrote a treaty
defending them and was subsequently
awarded the title fidei Defensor the
protector of the faith a title still in
use today
of course as everyone knows Henry is not
famous for his good relations with the
Pope but of course the opposite so by
1527 Henry had had five children by
Katharine and Albert won a daughter
called Mary had died or were miscarried
Henry saw this as God punishing him for
marrying his brother's widow and also
given the fact that he was
head-over-heels for some lady called Ann
Berlin he wanted his marriage dissolved
a quick sight now Henry never asked for
divorce but an annulment the difference
being that a divorce is a disillusion of
a legitimate marriage and an annulment
is where a marriage is declared having
never been legitimate in the first place
Henry asked the Pope to dissolved the
marriage but this didn't happen for one
simple reason
Charles v the Holy Roman Emperor so
during the previous war Charles v had
captured Roman with it the Pope Charles
was the nephew of Catherine of Aragon
and didn't want to see his aunt shames
her made it clear to the Pope no an omen
was he had been no help and Henry felt
that his position as a papal legate
meant his loyalty could no longer be
assured and so in 1529 Henry had him
removed his Lord Chancellor he was
replaced by Thomas More who immediately
told Henry that his marriage should
remain intact more would resign three
years later and so Henry appointed a
replacement called Thomas Cromwell
it appeared Henry wasn't going to get
his divorce and so in a small ceremony
he married Anne Boleyn because she's a
bit pregnant and I need to get married
before the birth otherwise the child
won't be legitimate and I could really
do with an heir
this act of bigamy was followed up by
Cromwell getting Parliament to pass the
act of restraint in appeals to Rome
which meant that clergy had to appeal to
Henry on matters of religion not the
Pope this act formally declared that the
realm of England is an empire governed
by one supreme head and king meaning
that Henry was in charge of everything
in the England was independent of all
foreign powers and influences
Thorin's marriage to Henry was declared
invalid by Henry and amberlynn with
crowned queen shortly afterward she gave
birth not to a son but to a daughter
Elizabeth in 1534 Henry pushed through
the act of Supremacy which declared
himself and his heirs to be the supreme
head in earth of the Church of England
in the same year Parliament passed the
treason act meaning that disagreeing
with this meant you'd probably lose your
head this was the case with Thomas More
who refused to go along with this and so
were headed Henry faced a couple of
setbacks in 1536 he had suppressed many
of the smaller monasteries in England
because of their close ties to the Pope
and had essentially taken all of their
wealth they sled two a couple of fierce
revolts in Yorkshire in Lincolnshire
which Henry defeated Queen Anne was
critical of this and combined with the
lack of some men she had to go Henry had
Cromwell dropped charges of treason
infidelity and even incest she was given
a slightly rigged trial convicted and
beheaded henry was then free to marry
another lady he was infatuated with Jane
Seymour which he did Jane would do what
the previous wives had failed to do she
bore him a son Edward in 1537 but due to
the complications of childbirth she died
two weeks later Cromwell was now firmly
entrenched in the position of power and
along with Henry began to reform the new
Church of England generally speaking
they towed a line between the Catholic
faith and the Protestant extremes
Cromwell also backed the printing of the
Bible in English although church
services remained in Latin and he began
to dissolve the rest of the monasteries
an event which has been given the
inventive name the dissolution of the
monasteries this was completed by 1539
and Henry made a lot of money from it
which he would promptly waste some
palaces and paying the debts on his
previous wars in 1540 Henry got married
again mostly against his will because
Cromwell kept nagging him to Anne of
Cleves Cleves is here by the way the
marriage was not a happy one and it was
declared unconstitutional from grace
before being arrested and then beheaded
in 1540 there is a pattern emerging on
the same day as chromos execution Henry
married Catherine Howard this marriage
would last for a whopping 16 months
before she was caught having an affair
which when you're married to the King of
England is not a smart idea she was
subsequently arrested tried for treason
and beheaded
Henry's problems weren't just concerned
with his marriages but with foreign
policy there had been numerous
unsuccessful revolts in Ireland and in
1541 Henry changed his title from the
Lord of Ireland a title historically
granted by the Pope to the king of
Ireland
Henry was hoping for war with France at
this point were needed to deal with
their Scottish Ally first Henry wanted
to unite the two crowns by Mary
his son - the daughter of the Scottish
King Scott refused and so war this war
is cut the rough wooing because Henry
was literally fighting the Scottish King
in order to force her marriage it was
also at this time in 1543 when Henry
married his sixth wife Catherine Parr so
in his late life Henry had become
morbidly obese and could no longer move
himself he suffered from many other
ailments and he died from an infection
1547 at the age of 55 the throne then
passed to his son who at the age of nine
was crowned King Edward the sixth who
would have the tough job of uniting a
religiously divided Kingdom thus ended
the reign of one of England's most
important kings whose decision to break
with Rome would dictate England's
foreign policy for the next two
centuries it is important to note that
little of this would have been possible
had his father Henry the seventh not
laid a strong and legitimate foundation
for his reign though I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
there are some book recommendations in
the description below if you'd like to
learn more
you